>> Mathieu 'p01' Henri: Thank you, so, hi,
first off, thanks a lot for having me, it's
my first JSConf 2014, and first time in Berlin,
it's really really nice, I really like it.
So does my daughter, she's having a blast
right now. As he said, my name is Mathieu
'p01' Henri, I'm a JavaScript developer, I've
been there for nine years now. I mostly work
on the desktop router. But most people know
me as PO 1, this is the name I've gone by
for about 25 years.
This is also how I got into opera, I entered
a contest and someone contacted me if I wanted
to join them, I said, sure, let's go. Then
you might be wondering what is the demo scene
that I'm talking about. Demo scene was born
here in Berlin 30 years ago. ‑‑ very,
very talented hackers, they take commercial
software, reverse engineer them, remove the
protections so we can use them for free. Back
in the '80s we were only‑‑ high score
tables, if it was a game look Pac M A N or
anything, or in the splash‑‑ of a program
we are cracking.
But in '84, Berlin cracking service did something
really unique, they added their own introto
program they would crack. No emission, no
sound, we're showing the emblem‑‑ it
started a revolution, soon the crack started
with this. Became more fancy, it became so
cool, these little demos were released independently
of cracks. Basically it's a group of creative
people that make real‑time audio‑visual
animations they try to push the technical
and creative limits, it's about pushing the
boundaries. Because it's born from that cracking
scene, it's very social, very competitive
the social part you can really see it in the
fact that every year at least 50 events all
around the world, mostly in Europe, but also
in the states, Japan. Some in Australia as
well. We have live concerts, seminars a bit
like here, we explain techniques and various
things. But, most of all, competitions in
many quality I goes, the queen category is
the demo competition where you have 65‑megabytes
124‑megabytes to make the most amazing real‑time
animation you can, this goes down to seven
size constraints, 64, and down to insane 264
bytes, it's not just about programming competitions,
it's also more artistic competitions like
music and‑‑ sorry‑‑ music and
graphics, so graphic competitions and also
short movies and animations, and uses many,
many platforms. It's also Amega ‑‑
>> Amega! It's also on 8 birth computers,
C 64, but it also goes on mobile phone, video
game consoles modern ones and old ones like
Vetrix, or genesis. But people also make demos
on the most crazy platforms, they make demos
on Oscoscops, some make their own custom hardware
just for the heck of it. This goes far, really
far. The most insane, I think in my mind is
also demos on OHP, overhead display we saw
in high school, junior high school, big lightbulb
on mirror, with plastic sheets people make
demos with that, it's just bizarre.
And‑‑ sorry‑‑ back then, back
in the '80s the main distribution platform
for demos was you take a stack of disks, send
them by mail and few weeks later you would
get your floppy disks back and stamps back
with more demos, and it would go on and on,
then came the BBSes in the '80s, '90s but
now everything is done on the internet. The
crazy crazy thing, which is not so crazy for
you guys is the web is a viable platform to
make demos. And, really it's about pushing
limits, and one of them is size, so how could
we go about making a small demo on the web?
Well, first of all you need to start from
an idea, a concept. So, your concept for your
small demo can be simple like just an idea
or a word or sketches. I have really like
to sketch my ideas on small story boards,
here you can see a couple of steps like, the
top, one, two, three, four, five, steps. And
something that I do now a bit more is to make
a mood wall. I just go on‑line and save
images over time and sometimes I see some
images inspire me and that could work well
together if I just combine them and animate
them this is the mood board for one project
I'm working on. We will see where this goes.
And once you have your concept, it's time
to prototype it.
The idea of prototyping is really to see if
your concept works, if it's possible in the
constraints you have. It's also about finding
the right technique to display your demo.
The web, first many way to draw things, if
you just want to do simple overlays, the DOM
is perfect, if you want to do street view
kind of things where you have a static observer
that looks around CSS 3D is good for that
theD canvas is okay, and for heavy duty stuff
againGL is king. Here's‑‑ web GL is
king. I'm going to show you a preview of a
project I'm working on. So hopefully this
should be finished in a couple of week and
we'll have sound sin crow anytion and it should
be, yeah, good. Still lots of work to do,
but I'll get there. So once you have done
your prototypes and you have‑‑ you can
do your ID, optimize it. When you want to
draw things to make animations you will play
a bit with numbers and a bit of trigonometry,
so, there's a couple of cheep approximations
of pie's and fractions of pie's that can save
you some bytes. It sounds crazy but when you
try to do something in 2 $56 bytes that helps,
you need it. Numbers in JavaScript you know
they're actually floating‑‑ numbers,
so the first two at the top, increments by
point one will end up with I being equal toll
10.09999 something this is because 0.1 cannot
be expressed in power of‑‑ power of
two. The second loop, since the increment
is one over eight, every number in this loop
can be expressed exactly so a loop ends with
ten, looks like nothing, it means during this
loop you can use modular and the modular will
launch exactly, so you can, in a cheap way
nest two loops by just using the right increment,
so that can save you a lot of bytes also.
But, really what you should do is try to reduce
your function footprint, so one thing that
J S told us you should use a function signature.
In this we have two functions, next one doesn't
need these arguments but by using the same
function signature, they will compress better,
so, just add a little bit of‑‑ but,
they will compress better in the end. But,
something else you can do is also you can
try oshadow things, in the case of functions
we have these two functions, two things, we
can combine them together, we can make one
function that takes two arguments, and if
one argument is passed we do something, no
argument is passed‑‑ we do the second
function. The same goes for code blocks, so
you can have one loop with us, yeah, but,
checks with value of one property, small square
and then put the next position, typically
that's in two loops, first would complete
the position and the second one would do things,
but you can do them together . But these things
are‑‑ they're nice but what you should
really do is simplify your idea. Simplify
your technique and how you will do things.
I had the project a few months back which
was called Minami district one thousand buildings
in one thousand bites and spin around. It
looks a bit like this, one common problem
or one big challenge I had was how coI know
which window to actually draw for each building,
so the common way would be the look at one
building and for each window compute the normal
vector for the window, but tells me where
this window is facing, if a Z coordinate is
positive it means it's facing towards the
camera if it's negative it's awhat. It's little
bit difficult to do with one K. So another
way I looked at it is think about how I draw
these windows one side of the window to the
next one if you follow the numbers, one, two,
three, four, if a number actually go towards
your right‑‑ towards your left, sorry
it means that the window is facing the camera,
so I draw it, if a difference in X from one
edge to the next one is positive I draw it,
if it's negative I don't draw it, it's facing
away, it was much more compact. So this other
project, which I called Matraka I wanted to
display some kind of crazy surface crazy object
with lighting and I tried many formulas to
describe the surface, I tried to use soft
code as surface, but, the best one was actually
the most simple, it was just Cos X Cos Y.
Very small bumps and the very nice thing about
this is that since it's very simple formula,
it's very simple derivative, and the derivative
gives me the curvature of this surface by‑‑
curvature so I know what is‑‑ which
light is‑‑ so I just take this value
and it gives me light office at a given point.
If you‑‑ in the mood board that I showed
you, like one‑‑ many, many triangles,
and, how you would do that normally is you
would process all your triangles together
and check the coordinate of the Lee points
and solve them, to know which order to‑‑
if the triangles are small enough, you can
think of them as‑‑ and just approximate
the particular so you just saw the triangle
individually and not‑‑ and it's much
more simple to solve this.
But, this simplification are often not enough,
you often need to go ahead and fake it and
you need to fake many things like graphics
you often want to figure out how to light
your objects and in 76 Jim came up with this
idea of environment map, what it does is basically
look at‑‑ in every possible direction
that the object can be facing check what is
your light, what can be seen in every possible
direction and makes a measure of it.
So, this is the image you see on the left,
well, you're basically sitting in the center
of the room and looks in every possible direction,
and you see in this direction you see the
window and this you see a door. And when we
want to render this kind of pea pot on the
other side you check what is the direction
that is the teapot facing at avarice point
of the surface and you pick and imagine, just
put it here and you're done. And you can also
extend this idea so when you‑‑ the image
contains‑‑ sorry that contains the color
that you would see in every possible direction
you can also store your position of your small
triangle or your reference of coordinate system,
so, you would store the color and also the
position of the small triangle in space as
if it was oriented in this direction, so you
have at all possible directions, which means
if you want to display a big amount of triangles
and have it with light and even with multiple
lights you can just do like one little cap
and you have the light and position of the
triangle and it's almost for free, so you
can do all this, all these kinds of cheating
and you often want to cast shadows to make
things look a bit more realistic and shot
shadows, it's nice to make it all soft and
more simple way to do it, as your draw your
elements in your fame, you draw‑‑ on
the floor in a separate canvas, smaller resolution
like a quarter or divide your resolution by
four or sixteen or thirty two, when you're
done you just expand your smaller canvas behind
your canvas where you draw all your things,
and by stretching it it becomes all smooth
and blurry I's very cheep and does the trick,
it really does the trick. And once you have
done that, well, good job, you have your visual,
it's time to think about the audio. And on
the web there's basically two ways to do sound,
web audio API and audio element.
Audio API is super powerful. It can do real‑time
sound analysis but it's a bit very bows, and
also regular 1 can and 4 K demos start with
a black screen and then the visual kicks in.
And that feeds very well with the audio element
because we have that much code, less than
200 bytes, you can generate sound and play
it. That's all you need. So, when you generate
sound you is to think about the Nyyuist frequency.
The Nyquist frequency, yeah, very Techi oh,
it's the lowst frequency at which you can
sample or generate music without getting audio
glitches. And it's basically twice the frequency
of your highest note in your music, so when
you generate music, generate at least twice
the frequency of your highest note, you can
generate higher, the lower the frequency,
means the less data you need to generate the
faster your introwill start. You will get
slightly lower sound quality, but your intro
will start maybe five or ten seconds sooner.
That can be nice. How do you make music with
that.
You start with small building blocks, you
need to build instruments, so, if you want
to do, I don't know, something simple like
a‑‑ you start with the first line which
gives you pure noise and the second line‑‑
decay, with a second and third line, of course,
it adds that to your music. And then, it's
nice, but, when since we generalsh rate the
music before the animations, how do we do
sin crow anytion with that? It's not that
hard, when you general rate the sound, you
foe exactly at which position in the sound
you have, so you can store in a separate area,
which notes you're actually playing at which
position and which volume. During your animation,
you can check the current time of your audioment,
multiply by sixty and you know where in your
sin crow anytion buffer you need to pick to
know which notes are playing and then which
volume so can do, you can really be in Sync
with your music, and once you've done that,
well done. But you haven't even started to
come press it. So ... the normal way to come
press is with JS packet, look at your code
as a string, look at the repeat patterns and
just replace them by a single character.
So if we have many archings if declarations
they would be registered to just one character
this is very nice, you get about 25percent
compression ratio and mini if Id code or on
the code I tend to write and you need about
70 bytes to decompress that, so it's pretty
powerful. But web parcels actually very nice,
we can‑‑ and this support GZIP in the
form of PNG images and we can bootstrap PNG
images the idea of boot strapping PNG, it
relatively new, you load your JavaScript code
will be gray scale image you save as PNG,
and when you load that and say, hey, that's
foo‑‑ I willowed that as HTML, so at
the end of PNG meta data you add HTML bootstrap
that look asbit like this.
So, what it does is basically it puts an image
but loads harsh‑‑ per page, the image
and loads it, puts the fix sells on the canvas‑‑
and with that you get about 40percent compression
ratio, the impact here is about 160, 170 bytes,
but it compresses at 40percent so at 1 K
you get‑‑ I've seen 4‑kilo byte intros
that were actually 20‑kilo bytes when not
compressed with this technique. Once you have
compressed your demo, it's time to bring it
to 11, so if you are above your target size,
it's time to really get dirty and to arrange
your code and trick it. You need to move the
code around and to try to increase number
of patterns so that the code come presses
better, sometimes just moving things around
how you set some CSS propertytion or different
values, just moving them around makes a difference
of five to ten bytes in the compressed ratio.
So it's‑‑ yeah, if you're above your
target you need to really shuffle things around
and sighe so how it goes, if you're below
your target size, also you have enough bytes
to actually work on the show, so it's nice
to try to not give everything away in the
first ten seconds. So, try to work on the
timeline, on the camera, so it's pretty boring
to see like 3 D objects, distant through‑‑
for 2 minutes nice to move the camera around,
makes it a bit more interesting, try to change
your color over time and space, to again make
things a bit more live and just not give everything
away too quickly. So now, I think it's about
demo time. So, here's a project I did a few
months back and‑‑ yeah. Here it goes
this is one kilo byte. just (Applause).
>> So, now this is your turn. I mentioned
many things, but it's actually lots of small
things, it's not black magic, you can build
these things with many, many small things
and just playing around with things, so don't
be afraid, this is not‑‑ this is really
not black magic, you can do it. And it's super
rewarding to do these kind of things. As I
said there's many demo parties, throughout
the year. The next one that I can think of
are function in Budapest in one month. Deadline
here in Berlin if one month and Demojs in
Paris in five weeks you have no excuse to
not make something and send them a mail, and,
some of these democrat mow parties have a
live stream where you can watch them compose
live. And it's awesome. Seeing your demos
on the big screen and hearing the audience
applaud and screen, it's like blowing your
mind, do it. It's so cool. Here's a couple
of web sites to get to know a bit more about
the demo scene. Yeah. Just visit them you
will‑‑ the last one, it can take thick
skin to take jokes there, so, again, thank
you very much for having me. It's a pleasure
(Applause).